Olá,
tudo bem pessoal? Um prazer estar aqui
com vocês.
Conforme vocês forem entrando, por
favor, me deem o feedback do áudio, se o
áudio está adequado,
se tá tendo algum estouro do microfone.
Bem, temos vários assuntos para falar
hoje aqui.
Por enquanto não tô vendo ninguém ao
vivo.
Bem, vocês pediram para eu falar de
pornografia e vício em telas. Então,
esse primeiro assunto que eu vou abordar
aqui.
Você sabia que o brasileiro passa em
média mais de 9 horas por dia olhando
para telas? Tem estudos aí recentes que
mostram que esse hábito pode estar
literalmente encolhendo partes do nosso
cérebro, pelo menos de quem faz uso das
redes sociais. Boa noite, Antônio
Renato. Por favor, me dê o feedback do
áudio. Então, meus amigos, hoje eu vou
contar algo que talvez alguns de vocês
poderiam preferir saber.
Bem, vocês que estão aqui na live é
porque vocês são diferenciados, vocês
são diferentes e eu acredito que todos
vocês aqui querem ver a verdade mesmo
que doa, mesmo que incomode, né? Então
eu vou mostrar o que que a ciência dos
últimos dois anos está revelando sobre
dois assuntos que todo mundo usa, mas
poucos têm coragem de discutir, que são
os perigos das telas paraa saúde e os
efeitos devastadores da pornografia para
o cérebro. Obrigado pelo retorno,
Antônio.
E eu não tô falando de achismo, não. Eu
tô falando de estudos publicados no
Journal of Behavioral Addictions, na
Frontiers Psychiatry.
e dados da Organização Mundial de Saúde.
Então, pega o caderninho, no caso de
vocês, nem precisa, né, porque vocês vão
tá depois acompanhando o resumo da live
e também, né, a marcação de tempo do
vídeo gravado. Vamos começar pelo
básico. Quando você pega o seu celular
de manhã, antes mesmo de você escovar os
dentes, o que que acontece no seu
cérebro?
Vamos falar sobre isso. Cada
notificação, cada like, cada scroll no
Instagram libera uma pequena dose de
dopamina. Isso pode parecer inofensivo,
né? Ah, porque dopamina é um
neurotransmissor aí relacionado ao
prazer, né? Então, pode parecer que isso
não é nada. Só que o problema é que o
seu cérebro ele não foi projetado para
bombardeio constante de estímulos. Isso
tá acontecendo muito no mundo atual e o
cérebro nosso ainda é muito parecido com
o cérebro de alguém de centenas de anos
atrás.
Então, um estudo publicado em março
desse ano na revista Curios,
liderado por uma equipe de pesquisadores
da Índia, cunhou um termo que tá
começando a ficar popular na internet.
Eu acho até um termo assustador, mas que
pode ser apropriado. É o brain rot, que
é literalmente apodrecimento cerebral.
Então eles fizeram uma revisão
abrangente mostrando que o consumo
excessivo de conteúdo digital estaria
associado à redução da capacidade de
atenção, o declínio cognitivo e
alterações estruturais no cérebro.
E esse dado
particular que eu vou falar agora para
vocês me assustou bastante. Em
adolescentes da Índia,
a prevalência do uso problemático de
smartphone chega a 64,6%.
Ou seja, tá chegando aí a 2/3, né? Na
Áustria, que é um país desenvolvido, 38%
dos jovens têm sinais de vício em
celular. Isso não exagera. uma
estatística publicada em periódico
científico.
Agora, o que que isso faz com seu
cérebro? Os estudos, né, especialmente o
estudo ABCD, que é um dos maiores
estudos longitudinais sobre
desenvolvimento cerebral em
adolescentes,
ele foi publicado noss jornais aí mais
tradicionais de medicina, que é o Jama,
é o Journal of the American Medical
Association Network Open. Isso foi em
outubro de 24. acompanhou mais de 10.000
crianças americanas. E o que que
encontraram? Quanto maior o tempo de
tela, maior a associação com sintomas de
depressão, ansiedade e problemas de
comportamento.
E pesquisadores de Harvard mostraram que
a luz azul emitida pelas telas, isso eu
falo já em vídeos há bastante tempo,
essa luz azul pode atrasar o relógio
biológico em até 3 horas. Então pensem
comigo, você olha o celular às 22 horas,
que todo mundo praticamente faz isso, o
cérebro acha que são 7 da noite ainda.
Então a melatonina é o hormônio que faz
você dormir,
simplesmente não é liberado de forma
adequada. Então tem um estudo que foi
publicado no Journal of Clinical Sleep
Medicine também em 24. Ele foi mais
específico. Ele demonstrou que a luz
azul na faixa de 400 a 500 nanôm suprime
a melatonina duas vezes mais que a luz
verde de mesma intensidade. Por isso
você deita na cama, fica rolando o feed
do Instagram e depois fica se
perguntando porque que não consegue
dormir. E a qualidade do sono vai pra
casa do, né? Você sabe que eu ia dizer
aqui? Um estudo tailandês recente
publicado na Plause One mostrou uma
correlação
inversamente proporcional entre o tempo
de tela e a qualidade de sono. Ou seja,
quanto mais tela, pior dorme. E sono
ruim, a gente já sabe, aumenta a
resistência insulina, diminui a
testosterona, prejudica a memória,
acelera o envelhecimento. É uma cascata
de problemas que parece ser sem fim. Mas
calma que eu ainda nem cheguei na parte
mais polêmica, naquela parte que algumas
pessoas podem eh não gostar desse
assunto.
Vamos falar aí de pornografia, um
assunto tabu, né? Muita gente não quer
nem ouvir falar, mas se você é membro
aqui da nossa comunidade, você sabe que
aqui a gente não foge dos temas difíceis
e vocês pediram, tivemos a votação de
enquete, a maioria escolheu que eu
falasse desse tema.
Então a ciência tá aí, ela precisa ser
discutida. Em 2019, a Organização
Mundial de Saúde incluiu o transtorno do
comportamento sexual compulsivo no CID
11. Isso significa que oficialmente,
internacionalmente, o uso problemático
de pornografia já é reconhecido como
transtorno de saúde mental. E o que
acontece no cérebro? Tem um estudo de
publicado no Journal of Behavioral
Addictions. Ele foi conduzido por
pesquisadores poloneses e alemães.
Esse estudo utilizou ressonância
magnética estrutural para comparar
cérebros de pessoas com comportamento
sexual compulsivo e controles saudáveis.
E qual foi o resultado? foram diferenças
significativas no volume de substância
cinzenta em regiões associadas ao
controle de impulsos e processamento de
recompensa. Um outro estudo que foi
publicado na Frontiers em Psychiatry em
mostrou que indivíduos com comportamento
sexual compulsivo apresentam
hiperatividade do córtex órbitofrontal,
que é a região do cérebro que atribuiu
valor a estímulos.
Então, basicamente, o cérebro dessas
pessoas está hipersensibilizado
para conteúdo sexual e dessensibilizado
para prazeres normais do dia a dia.
Então, em 2021, um grupo de
pesquisadoras encontrou normalidades na
substância branca, as conexões entre
diferentes regiões cerebrais em pessoas
com transtorno de comportamento sexual
compulsivo. Então são alterações
estruturais reais, são visíveis em
exames de imagem, mas o estudo mais
recente, mais impressionante foi esse
ano 25, foi publicado por Shu e
colaboradores, usou uma chamado FNS,
que mede a oxigenação cerebral em tempo
real. Então eles mostraram que usuários
de pornografia problemática tem uma
conectividade alterada no córtex
pré-frontal e exatamente a região
responsável pelo autocontrole, pela
tomada de decisão e regulação de
impulsos. Aí vocês podem me perguntar:
"Tá, mas isso afeta a vida real?" Pode
afetar muito, tá? Existe um fenômeno que
os pesquisadores chamam de Ped,
Ped, que é o pornography induced
erectile dysfunction. Então é uma
disfunção erétil, ou seja, impotência
sexual masculina induzida por
pornografia.
Homens que são jovens, são saudáveis,
sem nenhum problema neuronal nem
vascular, que simplesmente não consegue
ter ereção como uma parceira de carne e
osso real. Então, o cérebro passa a ser
recondicionado para responder apenas a
estímulos virtuais. Então, estudos
mostram que depois de semanas de
abstinência e pornografia,
muitos desses homens recuperam a função
sexual normal.
Isso é muito bom, porque o nosso cérebro
ele tem plasticidade, ele consegue se
recuperar,
mas quanto maior o tempo de vício, mais
difícil é essa recuperação.
E olha só a ironia, as mesmas vias
dopaminésicas afetadas pelo vício em
telas são afetadas pelo vício em
pornografia. Então é um efeito
multiplicador.
Você passa o dia inteiro bombardeando o
seu sistema de recompensa com estímulos
digitais. Aí à noite ainda adiciona
pornografia na equação, seu cérebro fica
completamente dessensibilizado.
Temos estudos aí com neuroimagem
funcional que mostram que em viciados de
internet há uma redução de 10 a 20% na
espessura cortical em áreas como córtex
singulado anterior e também a ínsula.
Elas são regiões críticas para empatia,
para consciência corporal e paraa
regulação emocional. Então, dados da OMS
mostram que o uso problemático de redes
sociais em adolescentes subiu de 7% em
2018 para 11% em 2022. Isso pode parecer
um aumento pequeno, mas estamos falando
de milhões, milhões de jovens com
cérebros em desenvolvimento, sendo
alterados por algoritmos desenhados para
maximizar engajamento.
Muitas vezes eu me pergunto se esse
fenômeno todo aí de hiperestimulação
por telas e por rede social, se isso não
é de fato um instrumento de guerra,
porque vários especialistas americanos,
pelo menos em relação ao TikTok, que no
próprio país China é proibido,
veja bem, a China desenvolveu o TikTok.
O TikTok é proibido na China. na China,
eles têm acesso a uma rede social
completamente diferente, que
eh dá ênfase
a questão aí de patriotismo, de estudar,
de aprender coisas novas enquanto o
ocidente consome esse lixo aí. Então,
muitos especialistas acham que a China
desenvolveu o TikTok como arma de guerra
de quinta geração. E isso pode estar
também se estendendo para outras redes
sociais, tá? A gente tem que ficar muito
atento quanto a isso. Pode parecer
teoria da conspiração, mas
isso é uma coisa que a gente tem que
manter em mente e proteger nossos
jovens. Bem, o que fazer em relação à
questão então do vício em telas e da
pornografia?
Não tem solução mágica, tem estratégias
baseadas em evidência. Primeira coisa é
reduzir a exposição à luz azul à noite,
usar óculos com filtro Ambar depois das
8 da noite e configurar o modo noturno
dos dispositivos. Tem aplicativos, né,
que você pode estar instalando tanto no
computador quanto no tablet, quanto no
celular,
que mudam a relação de cores da tela e
tira a luz azul. Eu mesmo uso o F.l aqui
no Mac. Então, melhor ainda, estabeleça
um horário limite para telas.
que o certo seria 2 horas antes de
dormir. Eu falo no consultório
geralmente uma hora porque o pessoal nem
isso eles estão eh respeitando.
E o segundo ponto,
pratique jejum de dopamina.
Então, períodos regulares sem estímulos
digitais permitem que os receptores de
dopamina se regularizem ou se regulem.
Então, comece com um dia por semana sem
redes sociais e depois vai aumentando,
se for possível. Terceiro, substitua
estímulos vazios por estímulos reais.
Tem o nosso amigo aqui Carlos Roveri no
grupo do WhatsApp dizendo que não
consegue localizar
o link da live. Vamos ajudar ele aqui
que o pessoal às vezes tem dificuldade
com essa questão dos links fixados.
Não sei se ele tá no grupo dois.
ou no nível dois, mandei aqui.
Então, vamos substituir os estímulos
vazios por estímulos reais, que seria
exercício físico, natureza, conversas
presenciais, hobbies manuais. O cérebro
precisa de dopamina, mas precisa de uma
dopamina conquistada, robusta, não uma
dopamina artificial.
E quarto ponto, se você tem problemas
com pornografia, reconheça, não é um
caso de fraqueza moral, é neurobiologia.
Então, existe grupos de apoio, existem
terapeutas especializados, não sei se
vocês vão lembrar, mas tem um ator que
no Brasil é muito popular, é um ator
americano, é um cara afro-brasileiro bem
fortão, ele ele é muito musculoso e que
ele foi lá o o astro do tanto daquele
filme As Branquelas quanto aquele
seriado que no Brasil é bem eh popular,
que é aquele do todo mundo odeia o Cris,
eu não lembro o nome dele.
Então esse cara, ele reconheceu o vício
dele em pornografia, buscou ajuda e é um
caso muito interessante porque ele se
expôs quanto essa questão que muita
gente morre de vergonha sobre isso, né?
Bem, isso é muito importante porque tem
muitos jovens hoje com 25 anos com
disfunção herétil por conta desse vício
em pornografia.
Tô Renato tá fazendo um comentário aqui.
Deixa eu
responder rapidamente, gente. Lembrando
que os comentários é mais para
acrescentar coisas do que responder
perguntas, tá? Isso aqui não é live de
responder pergunta.
Dr. Alan, no caso do jovem do formulário
que tem 28 anos, que tinha um bico
extremo. Bo, que que é bico extremo? E
semelhança com o autismo.
Qual recomendação para casos extremos?
Eu vi a resposta no formulário. Você
recomenda?
Como assim viu a resposta no formulário?
Eu não entendi nada, Antônio. Desculpa.
Tá confuso para mim aqui. Ah, tá. Você
recomenda, continua aqui, sair
totalmente das telas por quantos meses?
Depende muito,
depende muito
isso aqui não seria tanto caso de
suplemento, não. Seria mais caso
realmente de ficar eh fora das telas,
viu? E quanto tempo? Vai vai depender
eh muito de cada caso. Eu acho que eu
não tenho um protocolo único para
divulgar e o máximo de tempo possível,
tá? Eu acho que pode começar com mês sem
tela nenhuma. Aí seria um caminho.
Vamos continuar aqui.
Então nós temos uma geração inteira com
ansiedade, com depressão, com o suposto
TDH que eu acho que é fabricado por
conta desse excesso de tela.
Você
deve ter reparado que essa modinha atual
de falar que todo mundo tá com TDH,
todo mundo tá com autismo, para mim
parte desse fenômeno é essa questão do
excesso de telas que o pessoal tá
fazendo diagnóstico errado.
E tá só piorando a depressão, porque o
pessoal se compara com
os perfis do Instagram, que as pessoas
ali colocam uma situação irreal de
perfeição,
de metas que eles teoricamente
alcançaram, que ninguém consegue
alcançar ou a grande maioria não
consegue alcançar.
Hã.
Tá. Mas se eu fiz, se você fez a
pergunta, eu respondi a pergunta. Não tô
entendendo o que que você tá precisando.
Antônio. Renato.
Você não respondi. Vaiá, volta lá no
vídeo que eu respondi a tua pergunta.
Você quer fazer outra pergunta?
Lembrando que essa live não é para
responder perguntas, tá? Eu achei meio
confuso sua pergunta aqui, não entendi
direito.
Se você tá perguntando quanto tempo, eu
tô te respondendo, tá? No mínimo um mês
sem telas, mas isso não é um protocolo
fixo, tá?
Caso você acha que eu não respondi bem a
tua pergunta lá na na outra live, você
faz a pergunta de novo na terça-feira,
tá bom? Hoje não é para ficar
respondendo pergunta, é para interagir
com vocês, mas não para ficar
respondendo pergunta, tá? Se for uma
coisa rápida, até respondo aqui, mas é
para evitar esse tipo de situação.
Obrigado pelo comentário, Adriane.
Mas você concorda com quê? Exatamente.
Não precisa pedir desculpa, tá, Antôio?
É só pra gente deixar as coisas mais
organizada. Eh, pessoal, deixa tenta
deixar as coisas bem organizadas assim,
bem estruturada assim. Entenda, quando
você for escrever um texto, tenta
colocar ponto, colocar vírgula e tenta
evitar erro de grafia, porque dificulta
o entendimento, entendeu?
Ah, sim. Adriane, obrigado pelo pela sua
colaboração aí. Com certeza.
Com certeza.
Beleza. Você é um querido membro nosso,
viu Antônio. Não, não entenda isso como
bronquinha. Não é bronquinha, não. É só
pra gente organizar as coisas aqui de um
jeito que fique fácil para todo mundo,
tá?
Ã, eu não entendi direito que você que
você escreveu aqui. Eh, me parece tá
relacionada à pergunta que eu respondi
na outra live.
H, se você tivesse feito a pergunta
assim bem estruturada, assim, bem fácil
de entender, eu poderia estar
respondendo em poucas palavras aqui, mas
eu acho que o que eu falei pode ter
ficado claro para você. Bem, vamos
continuar aqui. Eu, particularmente, eu
não sou consumidor de Instagram, eu sou
produtor por questões de necessidade.
Eu não sou consumidor, tá? Eu prefiro
ficar longe do Instagram. Então, eu
basicamente consumo o YouTube. Por quê?
que eu acho que o YouTube é muito mais
interessante nesse ponto que você
escolhe os assuntos que você quer ver
naquele momento. Você vai no canal do
fulano, ciclano, do belrano,
escolhe o que você quer ver e obter a
informação que você precisa. Lógico,
temá o feed também no YouTube que te
sugere vídeos lá e frequentemente eu
também pego vídeos sugeridos,
porém eu acho que ele é muito menos
assim
disruptor no meu ponto de vista do que o
Instagram e outras redes parecidas como
o próprio ex, né, o ex Twitter.
Então, eu não tô dizendo para vocês
também se afastarem necessariamente do
Instagram.
A Dra. Ana Paula, minha esposa,
geralmente o que que ela faz? Ela fica
uma semana longe do Instagram, aí ela
reinstala o aplicativo
e aí ela fica, sei lá, uma hora vendo lá
os o feed do Instagram. Depois ela
desinstala de novo e fica mais uma
semana sem ver. Eu acho que é uma
estratégia que pode ser útil para vocês
se vocês gostam do Instagram.
E fiquem muito longe do TikTok, tá? Para
mim o TikTok sem uma arma de guerra de
quinta geração.
Tá bom, Antônio, não fica eh milindrado
não, tá? Com o que eu falei, beleza?
Pode falar à vontade aqui. Você é muito
querido, viu, Antônio.
Então, minha mensagem é essa. O seu
cérebro é o seu ativo mais precioso.
Você tem que proteger,
questionar cada minuto que você passa
olhando para uma tela. Eu geralmente
quando fico várias horas olhando uma
tela, é porque eu tô estudando alguma
coisa ou eu tô
eh realmente concentrado, tá? Eu odeio
eh ficar distraído com um monte de coisa
aleatória que que fica parecendo que
tinha um zumbi, tá? Então, sempre que
você tiver na frente de uma tela, faz
essa pergunta: "O que você tá vendo? Tá
construindo algo na sua vida ou tá
ajudando a destruir?"
Então, se a resposta for tá ajudando a
destruir, se for o conteúdo aleatório e
sem valor nenhum, se você percebe que
esse estilo de vida digital está
acelerando o seu envelhecimento,
prejudicando a sua biologia,
é importante você entender que a
reconstrução começa de dentro para fora.
Então, é preciso fornecer o corpo, as
ferramentas moleculares
para reparar esses danos, tá? Então nós
vamos falar aqui, o
Antônio Renato tava perguntando de
suplemento e eu falei que a princípio
não era suplemento era você sair fora aí
da dos estímulos. Mas vamos falar aqui
de umas algumas estratégias avançadas de
modulação metabólica e suplementação,
que não vai ser específico para a
questão de telas ou de pornografia, mas
que vai ajudar
na neuroplasticidade. Então, falando em
reparo e longevidade,
vamos entrar então em um dos maiores
desafios do uso de composto natural, que
é a biodisponibilidade do resveratrol. O
resveratrol foi um dos temas da live
anterior de duas semanas atrás. Então,
se você não viu essa live e você tá
inscrito agora, recém-cadastrado nível
dois, dá uma olhada no vídeo gravado de
duas semanas atrás e dá uma olhada no
documento
que também tem lá os resumos das lives
do nível dois.
Então, estudos fármaco-cinéticos que
foram publicados no Enels of the New
York Academy of Sciences mostram que,
apesar de aproximadamente 75%
do resveratrol ingerido ser absorvido no
intestino por difusão transepitelial,
a biodisponibilidade sistêmica, ele é
muito baixa, inferior a 1%. E isso
acontece porque o resveratrol ele tem um
extenso metabolismo de primeira passagem
no intestino e no fígado. Então, como
otimizar essa absorção? Primeiro você
usa o transesveratrol, que é a forma
biologicamente ativa e mais estável.
Segundo, tome com gordura dietética, já
que o resveratrol ele é lipossolúvel
e a sua absorção ele aumenta na presença
de gorduras. E terceiro, considere as
combinações sinérgicas que eu vou falar
aqui são muito interessantes. Então,
continua acompanhando.
Um estudo publicado no Journal of
Alternative and Complementary Medicine
avaliou a combinação de kercetina, que é
um dos ativos que eu mais gosto,
resveratrol
e curcumina na permeabilidade intestinal
em vitro. Então, os resultados mostraram
que o resveratrol a permeabilidade
aumentada em 310%
quando foi combinado com qucetina e
aumentou em 300% quando combinado com
curcumina e 350% quando os três foram
combinados com piperina. Então,
piperina, que na manipulação chama
bioperim, mais transveretrol
mais curcumina. Isso aqui foi um trio
top
para aumentar a biodisponibilidade do
resveratrol. Então, a piperina, que é o
bioperim, que que ele é? É um alcaloide
extraído da pimenta preta. Ele inibe
enzimas que metabolizam nutrientes. Ele
bloqueia a glicoproteína pedipato, que é
um transportador de fluxo e joga
composto de volta pro intestino. É como
se fosse aquele negócio, você joga lá
para dentro da corrente sanguínea e ele
joga de volta. Então ele inibeça
questão do efluxo. Então em humanos, a
combinação de curcumina com 20 mg de
piperina
aumentou a biodisponibilidade da
curcumina em 2000%.
Tá? Aumentou em 200% o resveratrol, mas
aumentou em 2000% a cocumina. Então os
dados pro resveratrol de maneira
específica, são menos robustos em
humanos, tá? Mais estudos em modelos
animais mostram que a piperina aumenta a
área sob a curva do resveratrol,
principalmente área de absorção, tá?
Principalmente por inibir a estatal de
glicuronidação
no intestino, tá? Então, além da
sinergia farmacocinética,
existe a sinergia farmacodinâmica
entre o resveratrol e a quecetina.
Então vai ser top essa combinação,
porque ambos são ativador de cirtuínas e
também ambos são
ativadoras da MPK,
mas vão atuar em pontos ligeiramente
diferentes nas vias.
Então, tem um estudo publicado no
Europeian Journal of Nutrition, que
demonstrou-se que a combinação de
resveratrol e que cetina teve efeito
cinético maior que a soma dos efeitos
individuais na redução de depósito de
gordura em modelos animais.
Então, a combinação inibiu uma enzima
chamado ACC, que é uma enzima limitante
da síntese de çocos gráficos, e aumentou
a ATGL,
que é um enzima que inicia a lipe, a
quebra de gordura, de forma que nenhum
dos dois compostos conseguiu de forma
isolada. Então, qual seria um protocolo
top baseado em evidências mais atuais? O
que que a literatura
sugere? Transesveratrol na dose de 150 a
300 mg por dia, que parece mais eficaz
do que doses altas de 1000 mg ou mais.
Então é bem interessante. Você pode
estar usando a quercetina de alta
absorção, que é o quercetin. Deixa eu
digitar aqui para vocês verem, porque
pode ser que vocês não vão entender.
Deixa eu colocar aqui, ó. quercetim, tá?
Esse aqui é uma quercetina de alta
absorção, porque se for uma quercetina
comum, você vai usar 500 mg. Se for o
quercetim,
pode ser 200 mg. Então você pega 200 mg
de qucetim, bioperim de 5 a 10 mg, mais
o transesveratrol
de 100, 150 até 200 mg. toma eles juntos
e vai tomando isso daí por no mínimo 12
semanas
antes de avaliar os resultados.
Então, populações com maior
probabilidade que vão ter benefício com
esse esquema são as pessoas que têm
obesidade, que t resistência insulínica,
diabetes tipo dois. Pessoal, vai
interagindo aqui comigo que para mim
fica muito melhor se vocês interagirem,
tá? Eh, eu acho que eu fui um pouco duro
com o Antônio Renato aqui. Às vezes eu
tenho que modular o jeito que eu falo as
coisas porque o pessoal pode entender
errado, né? Então, coloque a sua
contribuição aqui que para mim fica
muito mais dinâmico, muito mais
interessante, não me não me desgasta
tanto, tá?
Aqui, obrigado, Adriane. Já falou uma
coisa aqui, ó. Boa ideia da sua esposa.
Nunca instalei
TikTok, nunca gostei do Instagram.
Também não gosto de ficar distraído.
Eh, sempre seleciono muito o que estou
fazendo na internet. Distraído. É
Adriane que tá falando ou é alguém
usando a conta da Adriane?
Por favor, doutor, deixe a dose
prescrita aí para um jovem de 28 anos.
Não, a dose não é relacionada a peso,
não, tá?
Então vamos lá então. Ó,
pera aí, acho que eu vou usar aquele
outro recurso que tem aqui, o banner. Eu
vou deixar correndo na tela aqui,
que aí vocês ficam olhando lá lá na
parte de baixo, ó. Quecetim mais trans.
Qual que é uma dose mais conservadora
aqui?
Resveratrol
mais
bioperim.
que é o
que é piperina, né? E aí eu vou colocar
aqui um cúrculo, porque o volume é
menor, que é uma curcumina de alta
absorção.
Aí seria uma dose uma a duas vezes ao
dia junto com alimentos.
Pronto.
Deixa eu colocar aqui. Show.
Ah. Ah, como é que faz esse negócio? Ah,
tá. Vou deixar aqui um pouquinho. Depois
eu vou deixar ele scroll across bottom
para ele ficar rodando aqui. Pronto.
Deixa eu ver. Ué.
Ah, não sei. Acho que mudou esse negócio
aqui.
Era diferente isso aqui antes.
Hum.
Pera aí, deixa eu
deixa eu ver se funciona agora aqui.
É mudar o esquema aqui.
Pera aí.
Deixa eu ver se agora
timer. Ah, tá save. Deixa eu ver se
agora vai ficar rolando.
Ticker. Ué, tá rolando para vocês na
tela aqui? Porque para mim não tá
aparecendo embaixo não.
Ah, tá. Agora vai rolar. Pronto, entendi
aqui agora.
Obrigado por não ter sentido ofendido,
Antônio, porque às vezes eu ter que
modular a maneira como eu falo,
entendeu?
Ã, agora tá, agora tá rolando, viu,
Carlos? Agora tá rolando.
Deixa eu baixar um pouquinho mais a tela
aqui. Pronto. Bem, vamos continuar aqui,
então. Por que que o Resveratrol é um
ativo muito bom? mas que eu fiquei
bastante tempo aí meio desconfiado dele
por conta da baixa absorção, que aliás é
o problema que tem a cucumina, é o
problema que tem aquecetina, é um
problema que tem a crisina, tem vários
flavonoides aí que tem esse problema de
absorção, né? Mas se a gente começa a
usar essas estratégias para aumentar
absorção, fica top, né? E o resveratrol
ele é fantástico, que ele quimicamente
ele imita a restrição calórica, assim
como acontece com a berberina também.
que é outro ativo que tem que mexer para
aumentar a absorção, né? Mas e se a
gente aplicasse a restrição calórica
de verdade
de uma forma estratégica e programada?
Então vamos falar aqui da estratégia da
dieta que imita o jejum. Talvez vocês
daqui tenham escutado falar alguns de
vocês da dieta do Walter Longo. O Walter
Longo desenvolveu essa dieta que imita o
jejum. até comercializa aí umas comidas
desidratadas
dessa forma.
Então, vamos falar aqui de alguns
estudos muito interessantes sobre essa
dieta que mito o jejum.
E muita gente achava no passado que
tinha que fazer uma restrição proteica
muito intensa quando fazia esse tipo de
dieta.
Então, será que você sabe quanto de
proteína você realmente precisa quando
faz uma dieta que imita o jejum? Então,
pode parecer
uma coisa contrainttuitiva,
mas um estudo publicado em 2025 na
Clinical Nutrition,
descobriu que aumentar a proteína e não
diminuir, tá? Aumentar a proteína
durante esse tipo de dieta pode trazer
benefícios surpreendentes pro coração
intestino. Então, esse estudo envolveu
46 adultos saudáveis. Eles foram
divididos em três grupos. Um comia
normalmente, o outro fazia a dieta com
apenas 10% de proteína e o terceiro
consumia 30% de proteína. Então, todos
os grupos da dieta comiam muito pouca
caloria, apenas 850
calorias por dia, tá? Então é uma
restrição muito severa de caloria.
Então eu vou falar para vocês aqui o que
aconteceu no corpo dessas pessoas e como
você pode usar essa informação para
otimizar a saúde.
Primeiro vamos entender o que que é essa
tal de dieta que imita o jejum. E ela
não é exatamente passar fome. É uma
estratégia inteligente que você come
muito pouco, 850 calorias por dia, mas
ainda consegue ter os nutrientes
essenciais pro seu corpo não entrar em
processos aí que possam ser
prejudiciais. Então a ideia é enganar o
seu organismo, fazendo ele pensar que
você tá jejuando, mas sem os riscos da
fome total. Então essa dieta ela ativa
um processo chamado autofagia,
né? Que eu já falei isso em vários
vídeos, eu acho que vocês talvez sabem o
que que é, que é uma faxina celular onde
o seu corpo literalmente come as células
velhas e danificadas para se renovar. É
uma limpeza geral que você faz em casa
jogando fora o que não presta mais.
Nessa analogia, né?
Então, o que o estudo descobriu foi
muito interessante. Os dois grupos que
fizeram a dieta que restringe muito
caloria, que imita o jejum, perderam
peso de maneira similar, que era na
faixa de 2,3 a 2,7 kg em uma semana.
Mas aqui que a coisa fica interessante.
Apenas o grupo com mais proteína reduziu
a gordura visceral, que é aquela gordura
mais perigosa que inflama o organismo,
aquela gordura que fica no fígado em
volta dos órgãos internos.
Então, olha só, mesma quantidade de
calorias, mais resultados diferentes,
dependendo de quanto era a proteína.
Então, os dois grupos melhoraram a
glicose em jejum. em 10%, o que é
excelente para prevenir pré-diabetes ou
diabetes.
E a parte que mais surpreendeu desse
estudo é que o grupo com mais proteína
teve uma melhora significativa. Olha só,
o grupo com mais proteína,
proporcionalmente falando, ainda
respeitando os 850 kilocalorias,
teve uma melhora significativa na
variabilidade da frequência cardíaca. Eu
já falei isso em vídeos, mas já tem
assim, acho que alguns anos que eu não
falo nesse assunto. Então, a
variabilidade da frequência cardíaca
é um critério muito importante de saúde,
tá? A frequência cardíaca, ela não pode
ficar
o tempo todo igual, entendeu? Ela sobe,
desce, sobe, desce, sobe, desce, tá?
Então, essa variabilidade de frequência
cardíaca é um dos marcadores em saúde
cardiovascular. Então, que interessante
que nesse estudo o pessoal que comeu
mais proteína proporcionalmente teve uma
melhora significativa nessa
variabilidade de frequência cardíaca.
Tem um instituto nos Estados Unidos que
é o Instituto Heartm, que ele estuda
isso já há muitos anos e eles têm
dispositivos para ver essa variabilidade
aí da frequência.
Então essa variabilidade não é só um
número bonitinho que você vai ver no
smartwatch, que você vai ver
eh naquele a ring, né? Ele é um marcador
poderoso de saúde do sistema nervoso
autônomo. Então, quanto maior a
variabilidade,
melhor o seu corpo se adapta estresse.
Então, é como ter um motor que funciona
suavemente em qualquer rotação. Então os
triglicerídeos, as gorduras perigosas
assim em excesso no seu sangue,
elas só baixaram, olha que interessante,
só baixaram no grupo que fez a restrição
calórica, fez a dieta que imita o jejum,
mas que comeu mais proteína.
Opa, que que é no? Nope, o quê?
Eu não entendi o que que é nope. Nope em
relação ao quê?
Tá rolando aqui para mim? Deixa eu abrir
aqui no YouTube para ver se tá rolando
para mim aqui.
Vocês estão falando da da rolagem? Deixa
eu tirar o som só aqui para não
pera aí.
YouTube Studio.
Conteúdo ao vivo.
Deixa eu entrar aqui.
Ah. Eu
devia ter olhado o link, era mais fácil
ter olhado o link direto no grupo, né?
Foi pelo caminho mais difícil.
Ah, não tá rolando mesmo não. Pelo menos
o link do celular não tá rolando não.
Ah,
pera aí, deixa eu ver no outro aqui.
Pera aí.
Ah, sim. Só vai conseguir ver isso aqui
quem tá olhando o link do computador ou
ou TV, tá bom? É porque o Antônio Renato
tá acompanhando pelo, eu acho que ele tá
acompanhando pelo celular, tá? Quem não
tá vendo a rolagem é porque tá a ela tá
rolando em cima, eu acho. Ela tá rolando
em cima. Agora que eu vi aqui. Deixa eu
olhar de novo. Isso aqui
é, ela tá rolando em cima,
tá? Então, quem tá acompanhando TV,
tablet ou computador é embaixo e eh
retrato, né, que é celular em cima.
Beleza,
doutor? Não apareceu a fórmula. Tá bom,
vamos vamos mudar aqui. Eu eu tô vendo
aparecer aqui para mim, mas sei lá que
que vocês estão vendo. Então, vamos
mexer aqui no banner aqui. Pera aí.
Eh, off. Pera aí, deixa eu off.
Hide, tá? Hide. Vamos mexer aqui, tá?
Vamos tirar isso aqui. Vamos deixar ele
60 segundos.
Não dá para ser sem timer, não. Ah,
timer off. Pronto. É que eles mudaram
isso aqui. Não tava sabendo mexer até
hoje não. Pronto, save.
Show. Pronto, agora vai ficar aparecendo
na tela o tempo todo aqui, depois eu
tiro.
Bem,
voltando ao estudo lá da dieta que imita
o jejum intermitente, tá? O que
surpreendeu mais os pesquisadores foi o
intestino. O grupo com alta proteína
teve um aumento impressionante na
diversidade do microbioma intestinal.
Quando a gente pensa em microbioma, a
gente sempre pensa em fibra, né, que é
um carboidrato.
A gente não pensa em proteína, mas nesse
estudo mostrou sim que quem comeu mais
proteína teve mais diversidade no
microbioma.
Então,
para quem não conhece esse tema, pensa
no intestino como se fosse uma floresta,
né? Uma floresta tipo Amazônia. Quanto
mais tipos diferentes de árvores ou de
bichos, mais saudável é esse
ecossistema,
OK? Né? Acontece isso com Pantanal, com
a Amazônia, com a floresta atlântica e a
mesma coisa com as bactérias do
intestino. Maior diversidade significa
maior, ou seja, melhor digestão,
imunidade mais forte e humor melhor.
Então isso derruba qualquer mito de que
proteína demais faz mal pro intestino.
Então existia esse mito aí, isso estudo
tá derrubando esse mito. Então vamos
falar aqui de autofagia.
É aqui que a mágica acontece. Então,
durante décadas, os cientistas achavam
que para ativar aia você precisava
cortar a proteína de maneira drástica,
porque a proteína, como vocês sabem, ela
é ela é desfeita em aminoácidos e os
aminoácidos são os beuring bloquos, né,
os blocos de construção das células e
para fazer enzimas, etc. Então, isso
tudo mostrou que não é assim. A proteína
ela não eh tem que ser cortada para
induzir a autofagia.
Então, os dois grupos, tanto o de baixa
quanto de alta proteína, tiveram
autofagia ativada de maneira igual. A
diferença autofagia, de novo, autofagia
quando a célula come as organelas velhas
e se renova, tá? Ela come as organelas
velhas e produz organelas novinhas. E
também acontece aquele fenômeno da
células senescentes, células velhas
serem destruídas para dar lugar a
células novas, tá bom? Isso que é
autofagia. Então, a diferença, o grupo
que comeu mais proteína também manteve
melhor microbioma, como eu já falei,
manteve mais autofagia
e manteve melhor a massa muscular.
enquanto fazia essa limpeza celular.
Só uma correção aqui. O grupo que comeu
mais proteína teve melhor manutenção de
massa muscular,
teve
ah, a mesma limpeza celular no grupo que
teve mais restrição de proteína, tá bom?
Só que o microbioma de quem tava comendo
mais proteína tava melhor também.
Então,
quando você faz a dieta que imita o
jejum interemitente
e com a quantidade de proteína
proporcional maior, é como reformar a
casa sem precisar derrubar as paredes
principais.
Então, o que que acontece? O IGF1, que é
um hormônio relacionado ao
envelhecimento, ele caiu cerca de 35%
nos dois grupos, tanto no grupo que
restringiu proteína quanto que não
restringiu. E isso é fantástico, que
níveis altos de GF1 estão associados a
maior risco de câncer e de
envelhecimento acelerado.
E aqui vai um detalhe técnico
importante. O grupo com menos proteína
teve maior produção de corpos cetônicos,
que são aquelas moléculas que seu
cérebro usa como combustível quando
falta a glicose. É justamente o que eu
tô fazendo agora aqui, né? Eu tô fazendo
uma dieta cetogênica e tô monitorando
aqui, ó. Ó, tô com o sensor aqui no
braço, ó, que é igualzinho o sensor de
glicose, só que é um sensor que não tem
no Brasil ainda, que é um sensor de
cetose.
E eu nesse exato momento tô com 05 de
cetos. Tô assim começando, é porque o
almoço, o que que aconteceu no almoço?
Eu praticamente não comi
carboidrato, só que teve uma pegadinha
aí. Alguém jogou choio na minha carne e
o choio tinha açúcar. Então eu tava com
0.9
a 1 hora da tarde e depois que eu
almocei caiu para 05. Tá? Veja como é
tão importante a gente ficar monitorando
a cetose, tá?
H,
demorou para você ver. É porque
realmente acontece que tem um delay
entre as mensagens que você coloca e o
que eu vejo aqui, tá? Tem uma tem um
atraso.
OK. É, tem um atraso, sim. Eu acho que
esse atraso deve estar por volta de 1
minuto agora no delay aqui, mas vamos
lá.
Então, o grupo com baixa proteína, ele
produziu 0,6 mimoles por litro a mais de
hidróxibutirato
comparado ao grupo com alta proteína.
Então, o grupo com menos proteína teve
essa vantagem metabólica de produzir
mais corpos cetônicos, tá?
Vamos explicar o mecanismo por trás
então desses achados. A via emitor é uma
via bioquímica muito importante, é o
maestro do crescimento celular no corpo.
E como é que funciona? Funciona de uma
forma diferente, dependendo da
quantidade de proteína. Então, com pouca
proteína, o emitor fica mais suprimido e
aumenta a autofagia clássica. Com mais
proteína, o emitor fica parcialmente
ativo,
o que permite um processo chamado
reforma lisossomal. fágica,
que é tipo
a diferença entre demolir e reconstruir
a casa inteira versus fazer uma reforma
mantendo a estrutura. Então, os dois
funcionam mais de jeito diferentes.
Então, uma metaanálise de 2025 que foi
publicado no diabetology e metabolic
syndrome analisou 11 estudos e confirmou
que essas dietas que emitam o jejum
reduzem a hemoglobina glicada em 8,5
mimoles por mol em 8,5 pontos.
reduzem a pressão sistólica em 4 mm de
mercúrio e a diastólica em 2 mm de
mercúrio. Então são reduções pequenas,
mas são bem significativas do ponto de
vista clínico, especialmente se elas
forem mantidas, né, não forem uma coisa
temporária. Então, como aplicar isso na
prática? Então, se você quer tentar essa
dieta que imita o jejum, você começa com
5 dias consumindo 850 calorias.
Se você escolher a versão com mais
proteína, seria algo como 255 calorias
de proteína. Deixa eu colocar isso na
tela também.
380 calorias de carboidrato e 190 de
gordura por dia, tá? Isso dá
aproximadamente 64 g de proteína
vegetal. Deixa eu colocar aqui,
deixa eu ver uma coisa aqui. Deixa eu
apagar isso aqui.
Isso aqui também.
Isso aqui também. Isso aqui também. Dá
uma limpada nisso aqui.
Depois eu limpo mais, senão vai demorar.
Ah, então
deixa eu tirar aqui o timer,
deixa eu adicionar o banner aqui e
mostrar,
tá bom?
Então, esses 64 g aí de proteína vegetal
pode vir de leguminosas, né? Feijões,
grão de bico, lentilha, etc. Pode vir de
oleagenosas,
que são as nozes, macadâmias
e também de sementes, semente de
abóbora, semente de girassol. Então, se
você preferir a versão baixa em
proteína, seriam apenas 21 g de
proteína, mas com mais gorduras
saudáveis, como é o caso de azeite,
abacate.
Então, pode parecer abstrato falar em
calorias e gramas, né?
Então vamos desenhar isso aqui na
prática, como é que seria um dia típico
desse protocolo de resetabólico
com mais proteína, né, que foi o
vencedor do estudo na maioria dos
parâmetros aí. Então vamos lá, anotem
aí.
Imagina que você acordou,
você não vai comer pão, não vai comer
tapioca e nem fruta doce. Então, o café
da manhã seria chá verde ou preto sem
açúcar, porque tem aí os fitonutrientes
que estimulam autofagia ao acompanhado
de nozes, tá? Ou uma barra de nozes sem
açúcar
ou um punhado medido de macadâmias e de
nozes pecãs.
Então, por que que essas castanhas? que
ela tem muita gordura boa e pouco
carboidrato.
No almoço, o prato principal não seria
nem arroz e feijão, seria uma salada bem
grande, com folhas verdes escuras, com
pepino e rabanete.
Vegetais, então, com baixíssima caloria,
mas muito volume para encher o estômago.
E qual seria o tempero? Bastante azeite
de oliva extravagem de alta qualidade. E
qual que seria a proteína, né? Já
comentamos sobre isso aqui. Você poderia
incluir uma porção medida de proteína
vegetal, poderia ser tofu, tempê, um
scoop de proteína de ervilha, eh, batido
com água.
Então, qual que seria o objetivo? Seria
atingir aquela metaproteica sem disparar
a insulina. Então, aqui nesse caso, por
isso que a gente prefere a proteína
vegetal que dispara menos a insulina do
que a proteína animal, tá? Mas se você
não puder usar a proteína vegetal, você
pode estar usando um bife pequeno
de 150 g aí, tanto de peito de frango
quanto de carne, tá? E se à tarde você
tiver fome, quiser fazer um lanche, você
pode tomar um chá de hibisco, lógico,
sem açúcar, né? E azeitonas, porque a
azeitona é muito interessante. Ela tem
fibra e tem gordura igual do abacate,
né? Aquela gordura monoinsaturada
igual do azeite também, né? O abacate
tem gordura saturada, mas tem também
gordura monaturada.
E no jantar é uma sopa de vegetais sem
amido com abobrinha, com couve e flor,
com brócolis, com espinafre, batido ou
em pedaços e caldo de legumes caseiro
junto.
Então, se você fizer essa alimentação,
especialmente à noite, você vai dormir
sentindo o estômago leve, com um
pouquinho de fome, uma fome leve, mas
sabendo que as células não estão com
problemas, que elas estão trabalhando na
limpeza interna.
Então é uma dieta mutor restritiva, não
é uma dieta para fazer sempre, é uma
dieta para pessoas que têm cine
metabólica, não é para fazer se você for
esportista, se você for muito ativo
fisicamente.
Então é uma alimentação com comida de
verdade, mas com restrição calórica,
imitando um jejum intermitente.
E aí depois de 5 dias você vai ressetar
os marcadores inflamatórios. Aí você
volta pra dieta mais habitual, tá?
sabendo também que você melhorou a sua
variabilidade
cardíaca, né? Então isso é muito
interessante, tá? Deixa eu ver se tem
comentários aqui, porque eu tava
olhando.
Não, não tem mais comentários novos,
não.
Então, gente, atenção, né? Isso não é
para fazer todo mês.
Os estudos sugerem ciclos de três a
quatro vezes por ano, sempre com
supervisão profissional, nutricional e
médica.
diabéticos
que estejam utilizando insulina,
mulheres grávidas, pessoas que têm
histórico de transtornos alimentares,
devem evitar em fazer esse tipo de
procedimento, tá? Ou se fizer, que seja
feito com acompanhamento médico
rigoroso.
E, óbvio, né? Não adianta você fazer uma
dieta dessas e depois para os 5 dias
você se entupir de porcaria. O benefício
é muito mais importante
quando vem da mudança metabólica
sustentada.
O benefício vem da mudança sustentada e
também o time importa. Então, fazer isso
em períodos de menor estresse é muito
importante. Se você tá muito estressado
ou estressada, não faça uma dieta
dessas, porque o corpo já tá lidando com
a restrição calórica severa, que já é um
estresse. E se você tiver aí estresse
emocional adicional ou estresse físico
intenso, isso pode ser demais pro seu
corpo. E é muito importante também
durante o período de dieta restritiva
fazer uma boa hidratação.
Ah, tem um pessoal comentando aqui no
grupo que
não conseguiu localizar a live.
Gente, tá fixado os links lá lá lá em
cima
e eu escrevi de novo o link aqui.
Eu não sei mais como fazer aqui para
ajudar, porque,
ó, vou colocar de novo aqui. É porque o
pessoal fala muito, né, e aí acaba
mensagem fica lá para trás.
Então, voltando aqui,
hidratação é muito importante quando
você faz um jejum assim muito restrito.
Então, é importante tomar pelo menos 2 L
de água se você for uma pessoa pequena e
2,5 L a 3, se você for uma pessoa maior.
preferencialmente com um sal rosa, um
sal integral. É, pode sair duas colheres
de café rasas e 1 L d'água, porque isso
vai ajudar você manter os eletróles,
porque provavelmente você vai entrar em
cetose e vai perder glicogêno e perder
líquido.
Então, interessante aqui esses conceitos
que eu tô passando para vocês, desafio
que nós pensávamos sobre restrição
calórica. Então, por várias décadas era
considerado que para ativar a autofagia,
para ter os benefícios
anti-envelhecimento, era preciso cortar
muita proteína, cortar proteína ao
máximo.
Agora nós vemos que podemos juntar o
melhor dos dois mundos. Podemos
ter ativação de autofagia com
preservação muscular e com benefícios
cardiovasculares adicionais. Então é uma
mudança de paradigma na maneira como
entendemos nutrição e entendemos
longevidade. E tem mais, a reforma
lisossomalfágica que eu falei, ela
acontece com mais proteína porque
e também pode ser até mais eficiente
para ter a renovação celular a longo
prazo.
Então,
enquanto a autofagia clássica quebra
tudo, né, que você tá restringindo muito
a proteína, é como se você derrubasse a
casa inteira, né, e reconstrói a casa,
quando você faz essa mesma restrição com
mais proteína proporcional, a reforma
lisossomal vai reciclar componentes e
mantendo as paredes da casa ainda em pé.
Então essa reciclagem vai ser muito mais
seletiva.
É a diferença também em outra analogia
entre formatar o computador e fazer uma
limpeza inteligente de arquivos. Os dois
funcionam mais um preserva mais
informação útil.
Então pense comigo no impacto positivo
pra prevenção de doenças. Quando você
faz a redução de gordura visceral, isso
significa menor risco de sinometabólica,
melhora na variabilidade cardíaca
também, que acontece com isso, indica o
menor risco de arritmias e menor risco
de morte súbita.
a diversidade intestinal aumentada e
melhorada, né, com essa questão da
proteína que eu falei, o microbioma
melhor intestinal tá ligado a menor
inflamação sistêmica, uma melhor
resposta do sistema imune e redução do
risco de depressão. Então é um efeito
dominal positivo no nosso corpo todo.
Bem, e o que acontece quando o estado de
pré-diabetes não é revertido e quando a
inflamação e a glicemia alta persistem
por vários anos? Então o corpo lhe
começa a quebrar e um dos primeiros
lugares a sofrer são os nervos mais
finos.
Então existe um protocolo específico
para esses nervos que são mais longos e
mais finos, que chegam, por exemplo, até
os pés. Então, muita gente que tem
pré-diabetes ou diabetes tem neuropatia
periférica, né, que é caracterizada por
formigamento, queimação,
dormência nos pés, que geralmente piora
à noite. Então aqui no consultório, sete
em cada 10 pacientes diabéticos sofrem
com esses sintomas, sem saber que existe
uma substância natural capaz de reduzir
a dor neuropática, que é a dor que nós
temos nesses casos, né, por lesão do
neurônio, pelo excesso de glicose. E
essa redução acontece em até 40%. Nós
temos um estudo publicado em agosto
desse ano no Journal of Pharmaceutical.
Healthc sciences e descobriu que apenas
15 mg de áreas de crossina, tá? Vou
escrever aqui para vocês. Crossina, tá?
Crocina
que vem do açafrão verdadeiro.
Não é o açafrão da Índia ou açafrão da
terra. O açafrão verdadeiro. É o
crocosativos.
Crocos. ativos
tem
um
suplemento da Life extension que tem
esse, eu tenho até tem em casa isso daí.
Então, então é o crocussativos,
açafrão verdadeiro, de onde que é
extraído a crossina,
tá? Então nós estamos falando agora da
crossina.
Então esse ativo, ele é um composto do
açafrão verdadeiro que consegue melhorar
de maneira significativa os sintomas de
neuropatia diabética em apenas ve
semanas, ve semanas de uso. Então eu vou
mostrar para vocês um protocolo de três
passos para reverter esses sintomas
incapacitantes dos diabéticos.
Então vamos começar com uma historinha
aqui. Tem algumas semanas eu atendi um
paciente de 63 anos
que corresponde à média de idade do
estudo que eu mencionei. Então ele
chegou no consultório praticamente sem
conseguir dormir fazia meses porque ele
tinha pernas inquietas e tinha uma
sensação de estar pisando em vidro
moído.
Antônio Renato tá pedindo para colocar
de novo o protocolo de regeneração.
Vamos lá então. Pera aí.
Pera aí.
Não, não é esse aqui. Não é esse aqui.
Então, esse paciente tinha uma sensação
de tá pisando em vidro moído e tinha
síndas à noite. Então, ele já tinha
tentado o tratamento com gabapentina,
com pregabalina, que são os principais
remédios aí para neuropatia do
diabético, e até o uso de
antidepressivos.
Só que para ele nada funcionava direito.
Então eu implementei o protocolo com
crossina,
que é esse ativo extraído do açafrão
verdadeiro. Gente, lembrando vocês que
os vídeos sempre, sempre,
não tem nenhuma exceção,
sempre ficam gravados. Então, mesmo que
você não pegou, ah, não deixei na tela
aí o
as coisas, você volta o vídeo, depois
você pega facilmente. É só dar um dar um
print na tela, né? Dá um stop e um
print, tá bom?
Então, a neuropatia diabética não é
simplesmente um probleminha de nervos,
tá? Ela é uma cascata bioquímica
complexa que literalmente destrói as
fibras nervosas de dentro para fora.
Então a hiperglicemia crônica, ela
ativa, que que é hiperglicemia crônica?
Excesso de glicose no sangue vai ativar
a via do poliol e a glicose vira
sorbitol quando tá em excesso. Então
esse excesso de sorbitol da glicose vai
esgotar os níveis de nad pH. NAD de pH
deixa as células nervosas vulneráveis ao
bombardeio de radicais livres. Então é
como se os nervos tivessem literalmente
pegando o fogo por dentro. Porque a
sensação é essa, né, que parece que tá
pegando fogo
e não para por aí. Então temos também os
famosos produtos finais de glicação
avançada, os ages, né, a sigla em inglês
ages
e advanced
o e não lembro o que que é, mas é
produtos finais de glicação avançada.
Eles grudam nos receptores rage, né, que
parece fúria em inglês, né, raid. Então
eles grudam receptores rage dos nervos.
Isso dispara uma reação em cadeia de
inflamação, estess oxidativo, morte
neuronal. Então os nervos literalmente
vão morrendo aos poucos.
E é por isso que as pessoas que tm a
neuropatia sentem aquele formigamento ou
aquela queimação que vai piorando com o
tempo. E aí entra a mágica da corina.
Então esse carotenoide do açafrão
verdadeiro, ele não é um
antiinflamatório qualquer. Os estudos
mostram que ele trabalha em múltiplas
frentes de maneira simultânea.
Então primeiro ele reduz drasticamente a
produção de espécies reativas de
oxigênio nas mitocôndrias, nos nervos. E
em modelos experimentais, essa redução
chega a 65% do estresse oxidativo normal
do neurônio. Então a crossina ela modula
também o cálcio intracelular, ela
bloqueia o influxo excessivo de cálcio
extracelular e controla a liberação dos
estoques do retículo endoplasmático.
Então, com menos cálcio circulando
descontroladamente dentro da célula
nervosa, você tem menos
excitotoxicidade.
Então, é como baixar o volume de um
amplificador que estava no máximo.
Então, no estudo clínico triplo cego que
eu citei,
os pacientes tomaram 15 mg de crossina
por dia durante 12 semanas, tá? Então,
vamos lá. 15 mg de crocina por dia
durante 12 semanas para neuropatia
do diabético. Vamos colocar na tela isso
para vocês,
tá? Isso aqui é pra neuropatia do
diabético. Deixa eu até editar isso
aqui. Pera aí. Deixa eu editar
para vocês depois verem isso com calma.
Depois
então a dose baixa, mas o problema é que
esse ativo é um ativo caro, tá? Porque é
bem complicado extrair essa corina aí do
açafrão verdadeiro. Ele é um ativo meio
caro porque ele é meio raro, tá? Então o
total symptom score, que é um score que
mede queimação, formigamento, dormência
e dor, ele caiu de 6,6 para 5,1 no grupo
tratado. Isso pode parecer pouco, mas na
vida real significa voltar a dormir a
noite toda, conseguir caminhar se sentir
agulhadas e recuperar a sensibilidade
dos nedos ou dos nervos, né? Dos dedos e
dos nervos. Agora, veja bem, isso aqui é
uma estratégia. A gente pode associar
isso a hipoglicemente oral, a vitamina
no complexo B, a curcumina,
a beberina,
a alfalipoico. Então tem muita coisa dá
para fazer junto aqui para maximizar os
efeitos, tá? O mais impressionante então
foi a diferença do Michigan Neuropathy
Screening Instrument. Na semana nove, o
grupo de crossina marcou 5,7, enquanto o
placebo ficou em 6,8. Então essa
diferença foi estatisticamente
significativa e representa uma melhora
real na função neuronal ou nervosa,
não apenas mascarando sintomas, como
também
agindo de maneira que os analgésicos
convencionais não fazem.
Lógico, pessoal, não adianta ficar
tomando crossina do açafrão verdadeiro e
fazer tudo errado, né?
e continuar, por exemplo, com a
glicement controlada,
você vai est enxugando o gelo. Então, na
abordagem funcional, nós sempre
precisamos olhar o conjunto. Então, por
isso, além da corina, nós precisamos
implementar um protocolo completo que
inclui ômega-3 de alta qualidade.
Então, um estudo fascinante 2021 sobre
ômega-3 que foi publicado no Diabetes
Journal, mostrou que diabetes tipo 1,
aqueles que tomam insulina, né, que
começa na juventude,
eles usaram 100 mg de EPA e DHA por 6
meses e tiveram um aumento de 29% na
densidade de fibras nervosas da córnea.
29% de aumento na densidade de fibras
nervosas na córnea.
Então, a suplementação com óleo de peixe
melhorou a velocidade de condução
nervosa e reduziu a dor neuropática em
40% dos participantes. Então, a
combinação de crossina com ômega-3 cria
uma sinergia poderosa junto com os
outros que eu falei aqui, né? curcumina,
alfalipoico, berberina de alta absorção,
complexo B, especialmente aí a biotina,
a benfotiamina,
é muito importante também e também
colocar a carnosina, né, que é o
antiglicante. Então, enquanto a corina
combate o estresse oxidativo e a
inflamação local, o ômega-3 melhora a
perfussão sanguínea dos nervos e fornece
substrato pra produção de resolvinas e
neuroprotectinas,
que são mediadores que literalmente
protegem e regeneram tecido nervoso. Tem
um suplemento, chama-se,
deixa se eu consigo lembrar o nome dele,
que é rico em resolvinas.
que é justamente essa
substância metabólita aí do metabólito
do ômega-3. Me fugiu o nome agora,
daqui a pouco eu lembro, mas ele é bem
carinho, é difícil de conseguir também.
Na falta disso aí, vocês podem estar
utilizando o próprio Mega3, né, de alta
qualidade, que ele vai virar essa tal de
resolvina aí, tá bom?
Então, tem que ser um mega3 de boa
qualidade, que tem que ter no mínimo
1000 mg de DHA.
e 750 mg de epo por dia. Não, não é
colina, não é.
Pera aí, agora que você que você tá me
perguntando aqui.
Pera aí.
Ah, resolvinas. Deixa eu olhar aqui.
Produto comercial.
A gente usa muito para os ri esse
produto, mas eu usei pouco porque ele
era muito difícil de conseguir, era
caro.
Ah, tá. Lembrei aqui. É o tal do SPM,
né? Eh, o SPM, deixa eu olhar aqui na
Amazon.
SPM
é um SPM que é da Active Metagenics. É
esse mesmo. SPM Active. Deixa eu mostrar
para vocês na tela aqui, ó. Isso aqui é
um produto maravilhoso. Isso aqui é caro
e é difícil de conseguir no Brasil.
É o Specialize Pro Resolving Mediators.
É isso daí. Deixa eu mostrar aqui para
vocês.
Essa empresa aqui é bem top. Metagenic,
tá?
Estou usando rotato de lítio 5 mg e
gostando. Eu tomo já bastante tempo,
viu, Adriane? Quer dizer, não sei se é
Adriane porque você falou em um certo
momento como se fosse homem. Sono humor,
acho que sou um pouco ciclotímica. Agora
você usou no feminino, sou um pouco
ciclotímica sem diagnóstico.
Entendi.
De nada. Vamos continuar aqui então.
Ã, ficou redondinho. Ah, vou deixar
redondinho assim mesmo. Tá bom.
Ã, então
você vai ingerir a crossina, que é esse
ativo do açafrão verdadeiro, eh, na
forma de suplemento, porque é difícil,
você não vai achar o açafrão verdadeiro
na forma, tá? Você vai usar então os
extratos padronizados que garantem 15 mg
de corocina biodisponível.
O protocolo que aplico tem três pilares.
Então, o primeiro é controle glicêmico
rigoroso, mantendo a hemoglobina glicada
abaixo de sete. Segundo, suplementação
diária com 15 mg de corxina mais 2 g de
ômega-3 de alta qualidade divididos em
duas tomadas.
Tá bom? Então
isso aqui vamos colocar aqui na tela
também para vocês aqui verem aqui.
Então é porque em algum momento você
usou algum termo masculino, por isso que
eu me confundi aqui, apesar do nome tá
bem claro e a foto também.
Então ó,
ã, timer off,
banner show.
Pronto.
Então, o terceiro ponto é você fazer
modulação do estresse oxidativo com
ácido falipoico, já comentei isso, e a
vitamina B12 metilada, que é a
metilcobalamina.
Então, da mesma maneira que tem esse
detalhe para a curcumina, a coocina
precisa ser tomada junto com uma fonte
de gordura para melhorar a absorção.
Lembrar de deixar o ômeega-3 guardar na
geladeira para evitar oxidação, porque
ômega-3 anos pior a inflamação ao invés
de melhorar.
E os resultados vão começar a aparecer
entre a sexta e nona semana.
Então, o que que acontece? Então,
primeiro
você vai notar uma redução da queimação
noturna,
depois o formigamento vai diminuindo de
maneira gradual
e por volta da 12ª semana muitos
pacientes vão relatar recuperação
parcial da sensibilidade e melhora
significativa da qualidade de vida.
E obviamente nem todo mundo vai
responder igual. Pacientes com
neuropatia há mais de 5 anos ou com
hemoglobina glicada acima de nove vão
demorar mais para responder. Então pode
ser necessário aumentar a dose da cina
para 30 mg dividido em duas tomadas ou
adicionar outros compostos
neuroprotetores, como é o caso da
cetilcarnitina.
O erro comum
que eu vejo as pessoas cometerem é
desistir muito cedo.
A regeneração nervosa, ela é um processo
lento,
não é igual o sistema tomar um
analgésico, né, que vai cortar a dor em
30 minutos.
Então nós estamos falando o quê? De
reconstruir estruturas danificadas
ao longo de anos.
Então é necessário ter paciência,
necessário ter consistência
e exercício físico regular também é
muito muito importante.
Então, estudos mostram que 150 minutos
de atividade aeróbica por semana vão
melhorar a variabilidade da frequência
cardíaca, vão melhorar a função
autonômica em diabéticos, porque o
exercício aumenta o fluxo sanguíneo pros
nervos periféricos e potencializa a ação
tanto da crossina quanto do ômega-3.
Então isso é uma coisa que geralmente os
endócrinos não falam, né? A neuropatia
diabética pode ser sim reversível se
você tratar de forma precoce.
O problema é que a maioria espera
aparecer úlceras ou perda total de
sensibilidade para começar um tratamento
sério. Então é importante não cometer
esse erro.
Então, se você conhece alguém com
diabetes ou se você tem diabetes
que tenha qualquer sintoma nas pernas,
nos pés, sintoma neurológica, queimação,
ardência,
formigamento, perda de sensibilidade,
precisa começar o protocolo de maneira
imediata.
Então, além do estudo de 2025 que eu
mencionei, nós temos aí muitas
evidências. Temos dezenas de pesquisas
mostrando os benefícios da crossina. Ela
ativa
a via P3KT.
Essa via fundamental para neuroproteção.
Ela reduz citocinas pró-inflamatórias,
como é o caso TNF alfa e deteleocina 6.
aumenta enzimas antioxidantes endógenas,
como é o caso da superóxidesmutase e da
catalase. Então, é fascinante como uma
molécula natural consegue orquestrar
tantos mecanismos de reparos de maneira
simultânea.
Então, enquanto medicamentos
convencionais atacam apenas um alvo, a
crossina trabalha de maneira sistêmica,
restaurando o equilíbrio metabólico
celular.
Porém, sendo transparente, esse
protocolo que eu acabo de falar para
vocês não substitui o tratamento médico
convencional.
Então, continue tomando os
hipoglicemiantes, seja berberina, seja
metiformina, seja qual for.
Se for um insulino diabético, um
diabético independente de insulina,
seja tipo um, tipulada, use insulina se
for necessário, mas eu recomendo
fortemente que tem diabetes tipo dois,
evite o máximo possível utilizar
insulina.
O que nós estamos propondo aqui é uma
abordagem integrativa que potencializa
resultados e pode reduzir a necessidade
de medicação para dor longo prazo.
Então vamos falar aqui de efeitos
colaterais. Geralmente não tem em doses
terapêuticas a crossina é muito muito
segura.
Algumas pessoas falam, né, que pode ter
desconforto gástrico pelos dias, pessoas
mais sensíveis.
Isso geralmente resolve tomando junto
com medicamento, desculpa, tomando junto
com alimento.
Já o ômeega3, ele pode causar o boco,
ele pode causar um pouco de gosto de
peixe na boca e fees amolecidas se a
dose inicial for muito alta.
Então, para quem tem neuropatia
autonômica afetando o sistema
digestório, é interessante começar com
doses menores e aumentar gradualmente.
Então, essa situação da neuropatia
autonômica no estômago diminui o
esvazeamento gástrico e pode aumentar o
desconforto.
E nas pessoas mais sensíveis, você pode
começar com cxina 5 mg por uma semana,
depois sobe para 10 mg mais uma semana
até chegar nos 15. Então ômega-3 também
é interessante iniciar com 500 mg, vai
subindo progressivamente
e o investimento mensal fica em torno de
R$ 300 a R$ 400 pro protocolo completo
com produtos de qualidade farmacêutica.
Então é meio puxado, meio caro, porque a
crossina é cara mesmo.
Mas colocando em perspectiva, né, vamos
comparar isso com custo de consulta
recorrente, de medicamento para dor, com
fisioterapia,
né, e no risco de amputação, né,
pessoal. Pensa nesse ponto aí. Então,
prevenção sempre vai ser mais barato do
que qualquer tratamento.
Então, sabe aquele paciente que eu
comentei no início, depois de três meses
de protocolo, ele voltou ao consultório
emocionado, porque ele conseguiu voltar
a sentir a textura da areia na praia com
os pés.
Isso uma coisinha tão simples, né, que a
gente nem valoriza
que ele tinha perdido há há vários anos.
Então são essas pequenas vitórias que
fazem toda a diferença na qualidade de
vida.
Então, se você tá sofrendo com
neuropatia diabética, não aceite como
sentença definitiva
ou se você conhece alguém que tá
passando por isso.
Então, temos ferramentas poderosas como
a crucina, ômega-3, alfalipoico,
curcumina,
benfutiamina,
carnosina, né? Tudo isso é muito
importante pros diabéticos aí que tem os
problemas neurológicos.
Muito importante começar o quanto antes
possível. Cada dia que se passa com
glicemites controlado, a inflamação
crônica é mais dano acumulado nos
nervos.
E cada dia no protocolo correto é um
passo na direção da regeneração.
Quando a gente só mascara sintomas com
os analgésicos
ou com antidepressivo ou com gabapentina
ou com pregabalina,
você tá deixando de atacar a raiz do
problema.
Então, finalizando esse assunto, eu
quero deixar claro que esse protocolo
funciona melhor como prevenção ou
tratamento precoce.
Então, se você conhece alguém com
diabetes que não desenvolveu ainda a
neuropatia, pode ser interessante fazer
uma prevenção com crossina e ômega3
preventivamente para evitar esse
sofrimento futuro.
É muito mais fácil proteger os nervos
saudáveis do que recuperar nervoso que
já foi danificado. E a neuropatia
diabética afeta 50%, gente. É metade dos
diabéticos, tá?
Mas também existe um outro lado dessa
moeda da neuropatia, que é a energia
mitocondrial.
A gente precisa falar um pouco sobre
isso.
A gente falou em proteger o nervo e de
produzir energia. vai ser o próximo
assunto.
Como é que então o oxigênio chega na
mitocôndria
se os seus vasos sanguíneos estiverem
rígidos ou tiverem fechados?
Então, existe um vegetal raiz super
comum na feira que contém uma molécula
que é capaz de fazer as mitocôndrias
funcionarem com menos oxigênio e ao
mesmo tempo abrir as artérias como se
fosse uma via expressa. Qual seria esse
vegetal?
Vamos falar aqui, fazer um pouquinho de
suspense, né? Que rufem os tambores, mas
talvez vocês tenham já adivinhado
que nós estamos falando aqui da
beterraba.
A beterraba é rica em nitratos e o
nitrato em contato com estômago, com
ácido estômago vira nitrito. Esse
nitrito vira óxido nítrico. Tem uma
revisão sistemática que foi publicada em
2025 e analisou o impacto, né, da
beterraba na doença arterial periférica
e na capacidade de exercício.
Então vamos falar aqui um pouquinho
sobre como é que funciona o óxido
nítrico. Quando você ingere nitrato, que
tem na beterraba, no espinafre, na
couve, na rúcula, bactérias
específicas da língua convertem o
nitrato e nitrito.
E quando bate no estômago, aí que vira
óxido nítrico, tá? Já falei um pouco
errado antes. Então, a conversão em
nitrato e nitrito acontece na saliva
pelas bactérias e quando bate no
estômago viróxido nítrico.
Então, quando você engole esse nitrito,
ele vira óxido nítrico no estômago. E o
óxido nítrico é um gás sinalizador
potente que relaxa a musculatura lisa
dos vasos sanguíneos e isso provoca vaso
dilatação. O sango, o sangue flui com
mais facilidade.
a pressão baixa e os nutrientes chegam
onde devem chegar.
A maioria das pessoas não sabe, é que é
fascinante também para quem gosta de
mitocôndria, é que o óxido nítrico ele
melhora a eficiência mitocondrial,
ele reduz o custo de oxigênio no
exercício.
Então é como se o carro, o seu carro
conseguisse andar mais quilômetros com o
mesmo litro de gasolina.
Então, para quem tem fadiga crônica,
insuficiência cardíaca, neuropatia,
quando o fluxo de sangue pro nevoí
da beterraba. Então, a revisão de 2025
mostrou que o suco de beterraba pode
melhorar a distância de caminhada e
reduzir a pressão arterial em pessoas
com problemas circulatórios nas pernas.
E tem um outro pulo do gato que derruba
muita gente, que é o uso do enxaguante
bucal.
Já falei isso em vídeos anos atrás.
Lembra que eu disse que as bactérias da
língua ou da boca fazem a primeira
conversão de nitrato e nitrito. Então,
se você usa um enxagoncal
antiséptico, você mata essas bactérias e
anula completamente o efeito positivo da
beterraba. Então não pode usar
listerine, cepacol, você não deve
utilizar esse tipo de mecanismo. Você
pode utilizar, na verdade o o pulling,
né, que você usa o óleo de coco para
limpar a boca, mas não deve utilizar
esses ã colutórios, né, esses
antisséticos bucais aí comuns.
Então é muito importante você não
utilizar isso e utilizar a beterraba na
forma de suco concentrado ou extratos
padronizados que sejam ricos em betaína
nidra, né? Não é a mesma coisa que
cloridrate betaína e utilizar isso cerca
de 2 horas antes do treino ou da
atividade física e abolir os enxaguantes
bucais agressivos.
E quando você tem o óxido nítrico aí em
níveis adequados, você vai ter uma
potencialização
da vitamina D, da própria cxina que eu
comentei e a mitocôndria vai respirar
aliviada com mais oxigênio.
Então,
a crossina e os nitratos podem tratar
danos crônicos que foram acumulados ao
longo de anos.
E quando o problema é agudo, como é que
a gente faz?
Você pode ser pego de surpresa por uma
infecção viral intensa e precisa baixar
a inflamação de maneira rápida.
Então nós temos aí dois ingredientes que
provavelmente estão na sua cozinha que
podem reduzir, né, os marcadores
inflamatórios em até 50% durante uma
infecção viral, né, que é uma doença
aguda.
Então, temos o estudo triplo cego
publicado no em agosto de 2025 no
Scientific Reports, testou a cúrcuma e o
gengibre em pacientes com Covid-19
e os resultados foram impressionantes.
Então vamos falar aqui exatamente como é
que foi, o que que a ciência descobriu,
as dosagens utilizadas e como você pode
aplicar isso na prática. Então a gente
sabe que a inflamação é o grande vilão
das infecções virais, não é o vírus em
si que causa a maior parte dos danos, é
a resposta inflamatória descontrolada do
corpo, né? Então, cúrcuma e gengibre em
pacientes com COVID-19.
o seu sistema imunológico, ele quer
ajudar, mas às vezes ele exagera na
dose, né? A gente viu isso durante a
pandemia, né? Naquelas reações
exacerbadas do sistema imune gerando eh
internações na UTI. Muita gente teve
aquelas tempestades inflamatórias e
morreu por conta disso.
E aí que entra esses dois aliados
poderosos da natureza.
pesquisadores do Hospital Colusar, que é
no Irã, eles conduziram um ensaio
clínico randomizado triplo cego, com 144
pacientes ambulatoriais diagnosticados
com COVID-19.
Então, triplo cego significa que nem os
pacientes, nem os médicos, nem os
pesquisadores sabiam quem estava tomando
o quê. OK? Então isso elimina qualquer
tipo de viés, né, de eh questão aí de
forçar o estudo para um lado e pro outro
e pode garantir uns resultados mais
confiáveis. Os participantes foram
divididos em três grupos. Um recebeu
cúrcuma, outro recebeu gengibre e o
terceiro placebo, né, a pílula de
farinha. Então foi 500 mg três vezes ao
dia
durante 5 dias, tanto de cúrcuma como
gengibre como placebo.
Então isso totalizou 1500 mg de aros de
cada substância.
E aqui vem o dado que chamou mais
atenção. A proteína ser reativa, aquele
marcador inflamatório que a gente pede
nos exames de sangue, ele caiu 4 mg por
L no grupo da cúrcuma e 6 mg por L no
grupo do gengibre.
Já a velocidade hemsedimentação VHS, que
é outro marcador clássico de inflamação,
ele reduziu 5 mm/h com cúrcuma e 9 mm/h
com gengibre.
Então, no placebo, obviamente
praticamente nada mudou.
Agora, presta atenção nesse detalhe.
Estatisticamente não houve diferença
significativa entre cúrcuma e gengibre.
Ambos funcionaram de maneira
equivalente.
O valor de P paraa comparação entre os
dois foi de 0,2. Ou seja, os dois são
igualmente eficazes como
antiinflamatórios nesse contexto do
COVID. pelo menos nesse estudo do Irã
aí.
Então, se você tem acesso mais fácil a
um do que ao outro, você pode usar
qualquer um com confiança se tiver
alguma infecção viral, mas realmente eu
sugeriria vocês utilizarem os dois
juntos.
Então, a curcumina, né, o composto ativo
da cúrcuma, né, que já falamos bastante
deles aqui no canal,
ele inibe a via do NFK beta, que é
praticamente o maestro da orquestra
inflamatória do corpo. E quando você
bloqueia essa via, você reduz a produção
de citocinas inflamatórias, como é o
caso de teleucina 6, do TNF alfa. E o
gengibre tem os compostos chamados
gingeróis,
que
também atuam nessa via inflamatória,
inibem também a cicloxigenase 2, a cox
2, que é o mesmo alvo de
anti-inflamatórios como o ibuprofeno,
só que obviamente sem os efeitos
colaterais do ibuprofeno.
Então, um ponto que o estudo deixou
claro
é que nem a cúrcuma nem o gengibre
alteraram de maneira significativa os
níveis de LD LDL, não, desculpe, de LDH
e também
a contagem glóbulos brancos.
Então isso sugere que esses compostos
atuam mais na modulação da resposta
inflamatória
do que na prevenção direta do dano
celular nas fases iniciais de infecção.
Então, ou seja, eles ajudam a controlar
o fogo, mas não impedem que o fósforo
seja riscado.
E que vai uma dica prática que foi
baseada na minha experiência clínica,
né? Então, que já falamos aqui várias
vezes desse assunto, vamos falar de
novo.
A biodisponibilidade
da curcumina é baixa, sozinha, ela é mal
absorvida.
Por isso tem que usar uma curcumina ou
que tenha piperina
ou uma curcumina que tenha fitossomos ou
algum composto aumenta a absorção da
cucumina através de nanotecnologia, né,
daqueles lipossomais.
Então, o estudo publicado
em 2022
usou exatamente a combinação 500 mg de
curcumina, 5 mg de piperina na forma de
bioperim, né? Duas vezes ao dia.
E um dado interessante, pesquisas com
nanocurcumina, que é a curcumina e
nanopartícula,
mostrou reduções maiores dos marcadores
inflamatórios, tá? incluindo dedímero,
ferritina e teleucina 6 após 14 dias de
uso. Então, a tecnologia de
nanopartícula resolve problema de
absorção de forma elegante,
porém torna o produto mais caro, tá?
Agora, o gengibre tem uma vantagem. O
gengibre ele não tem esse problema de
biodisponibilidade, não precisa de
tecnologias grandes aí para
o gengibre ser absorvido.
Então, a dosagem que foi utilizada nesse
estudo de 1500 mg por dia em três
tomadas,
ou seja, dividido 1500 mg em três doses
de 500 mg, ela é segura tanto paraa
cucumina quanto para o gengibre e é bem
tolerado pela grande maioria das
pessoas.
E você pode usar também o gengibre na
forma fresca e ralada, OK?
Então esse estudo foi feito com
pacientes que já estavam recebendo
tratamento padrão paraa COVID, tá? Então
isso foi adicional
e a cúrcuma e o gengibre foram
utilizados como terapias complementares
e não de substituição. Então por favor
tomem cuidado. Se você tiver uma
infecção viral aí
não largue o seu tratamento ortodoxo.
A visão funcional muitas vezes tem que
ser complementar. e a gente vai somar
estratégias e não subtrair.
Então, paraa prevenção geral e
manutenção da saúde, você pode utilizar
doses menores de curcumina, né, de 500 a
1000 mg por dia, se for a forma com
piperina ou 1 a 2 g de gengibre por dia.
Em situações de infecções agudas, virais
ou inflamação aumentada, você pode subir
pra as doses do estudo que foram 1500 mg
divididas em três tomadas. E tente fazer
isso com acompanhamento profissional.
Gente, vocês estão muito calados aí que
tem mais alguém aí? Tá todo mundo
dormindo?
Eh, vocês não querem fazer nenhum
comentário?
Então, eu prefiro combinar os dois, tá?
Eu 500 mg de cucumina mais 500 gengibre,
né? se não for aquela curcumina tipo
cucuva, né? e tá tomando isso daí eh
umas duas vezes ao dia ou uma vez ao
dia, dependendo do caso.
Então essa combinação
da cúrcuma com o gengibre aproveita os
mecanismos complementares de ação
e distribui atividade antiinflamatória
ao longo do dia.
Obrigado, Carlos, aí pelo seu
comentário, tá?
Lembrando que curcumina em doses altas
pode ter efeito anticoagulante leve.
Cuidado se você utiliza vafarina ou
outros outros anticoagangulantes.
O gengibre pode interagir com
medicamentos para diabetes e pode
potencializar a queda de glicose. Então,
tem que fazer ajuste do remédio
diabetes.
E ambos devem ser evitados
em doses terapêuticas por gestantes e
orientação médica.
Então, que esse estudo nos mostra que
temos ferramentas naturais acessíveis e
cientificamente comprovadas para modular
resposta inflamatória do corpo.
De novo, pessoal, 500 mg de cúrcuma ou
gengibre três vezes ao dia na fase
aguda. Durante 5 dias pode reduzir
marcadores inflamatórios de infecção
viral ativa.
Isso foi publicado em revista científica
Scientific Reports, que é um dos jornais
mais respeitados do mundo.
E você pode utilizar doses menores de
prevenção se você quiser,
né? Especialmente se você tá numa época
do ano aí que você tem um risco maior de
pegar uma virose.
Bem, pessoal, vou encerrar esse assunto
aqui eh dessa live.
Temos mais um assunto para abordar, mas
eu vou deixar para semana que vem, que
eu já tô ficando meio cansado aqui de
falar. E eu ainda tenho outra live que
eu vou ter que entrar aqui porque o
nosso amigo aí, o Luiz Sterne, pediu
para eu dar uma aulinha de meia hora
numa live que ele tem de domingo lá.
Então eu vou deixar esse assunto pra
semana que vem. esse esse último aqui
que é sobre
o ultravioleta endovenoso.
Deixa eu fechar aqui.
Criar um outro documento.
Não, não é esse aqui não. Pera aí.
Então isso aqui fica como se fosse a
live. Se bem que tem que ver se vocês
vão ter interesse ter live.
Daqui a duas semanas já é Natal, né?
Deixa eu ver aqui a data que vai cair.
Eu não vou viajar, né? Para mim faz
pouca diferença.
Já viajei, né? Cadê o calendário? Não tô
achando. Cadê?
Ah, eu acho que eu fechei o calendário.
Pera aí.
Ah, dia 28, né? Vai ser depois de Natal
já.
É, vou deixar essa esse esse material
pra live do dia 28.
Pessoal, para você tá produtivo fazer
essas lives longas assim
ou será que a gente deve fazer lives
mais frequentes e mais curtas? Talvez
meia hora.
Fazer meia hora semanal de domingo em
vez de fazer 2 horas, quase 2 horas. Que
que vocês acham?
Ivan
Ivan Antonieto, né? O IF Antonieto.
O uso de cocoflex da Biobalance de 920
mg, macaco por dia já ajuda na
prevenção? Com certeza. Com certeza.
Esse produto aí é muito bom. Ele tem uma
tecnologia que melhora a
biodisponibilidade.
Inclusive tem na cirúrgica bergamota. Se
vocês quiserem comprar,
tá bom?
Será que eu tenho esse link aqui da
cirúrgica BH Moto? Acho que eu tenho.
Pera aí.
Acho que eu tenho aqui. Pera aí,
ó. Eh, mas a o link exato
da cucumina é essa que ele comentou
aqui. Deixa eu olhar aqui.
Deixa eu achar aqui. Ah, tá, achei.
Ã, não, mas esse aqui é do é do site.
É da foto. Vamos, vamos entrar aqui no
curcoflex.
Pronto. Deixa eu colocar o link na tela
aqui.
Vou deixar aqui com timer off.
Adicionar. Show. Pronto.
Esse é o link da do produto da cirúrgica
bergamota que tem o Cocoflex.
Doutor, boa noite. Tive que tomar duas
doses da picada.
Pois é, Juliana.
Aí eu recomendo que você tome
piqulogenol,
natoquinas,
talvez a dose baixa de vimectina, tá
bom? Para evitar problemas de trombos
aí.
NAC também, eu falo isso em várias
lives, né?
Bem, pessoal, tá batendo 8 horas,
então eu vou encerrar a live, tá bom?
Obrigado que vocês interagiram bem mais
nessa live do que na live anterior. Teve
mais gente também.
Que que eu acho da Zeólita? Acho muito
bom. Você provavelmente não sabe,
Juliana, mas eu tenho um vídeo sobre
Zeólita, mas ele tá mais antigo. Procura
lá no meu canal. Deixa eu mostrar para
vocês aqui. É que tem coisa que eu tive
que tirar por causa do
grande irmão, né, do YouTube.
Vamos procurorar aqui o vídeo da
Zeólita.
Ixe, não tá aqui mesmo. Acho que eu tive
que tirar esse vídeo do ar. Pera aí,
deixa eu procurar aqui de uma outra
maneira.
Pera aí.
Se não tiver aqui, tem no Rumble.
Zeólita
Alaim Dutra Alan Dutra. Vamos ver.
Achei. Achei. Hum. Por que que não
apareceu? Ah, porque tá com Zeolite. É
por isso.
Então, olha, deixa eu mostrar aqui para
vocês o vídeo.
Pera aí. Não, deixa eu voltar aqui.
Pera aí que eu vou mostrar.
Ah, stop screen, presente,
share. Pronto. Aí, ó.
Zeolit,
105.000 visualizações 7 anos atrás. Olha
a minha carinha aqui de tava mais
magrinho nessa, nesse vídeo aqui. Eu
tinha, acho que eu tava fazendo até
dieta cetogênica nessa época aqui, ó.
Eu gostava dessa vinhetinha aqui, viu?
Mas aí tem que tirar a vinheta que o
povo hoje não tem mais tolerância
a vinheta não. Olha minha carinha aqui
de magrinho aqui, ó. Ã,
tem 7 anos isso aqui.
Belê.
Tá bom,
pessoal. Então é isso, muito obrigado
pela presença de vocês.
A gente se vê então na terça-feira na
live de apoiadores, tá bom?
É Ivan Tonieto Brugali, isso aí quando
junta tudo aí fica mais difícil de ler.
Pessoal, um beijo no coração de vocês.
Até a próxima, tá? Vou entrar na outra
live lá.